madame monsieur bonsoir et bienvenue
pour notre débat d'entre deux tours sur
france 3 bourgogne nous sommes en direct
pendant une heure pour évoquer le
deuxième tour des élections municipales
à nevers nevers un fief historique de la
gauche depuis plus de 40 ans me verts où
l'issue du scrutin est particulièrement
incertaine le maire sortant socialiste
florent sainte fare garnot est arrivé en
tête avec 35% des voix mais l'alliance
entre les deux tours des candidats de
droite ump udi avec le candidat sans
étiquette denis thuriau arrivé lui en
deuxième position avec plus de 23% des
voix a totalement modifié la donne de
cette élection
alors pour débattre de cette situation
et des programmes des candidats les
chefs de file de ces trois listes sont
sur notre plateau ce soir florent sainte
fare garnot bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
maire sortant et candidat à la tête de
la liste ps pc europe écologie du préfet
denis thuriau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le candidat sans étiquette et entre les
deux tours vous à les fusionner avec les
deux listes ump et u10 et christophe
gaillard bonsoir comme au premier tour
vous mener la liste du front national
alors chez vous vous pouvez intervenir
dans ce débat et réagir bien sûr via les
réseaux sociaux comme d'habitude hashtag
lvl la bourgogne au hashtag f3 bourgogne
pour commencer ce débat nous allons
forcément devoir nous pencher sur cet
entre deux tours qui nous le disions en
introduction a totalement changé la
donne puisque les deux candidats ump udf
philippe cordier guillaume maillard qui
ne s'étaient pas entendus avant le
premier tour se sont rangés derrière
vous denis thuriau votre campagne était
basée sur la politique mme l'êtes vous
toujours où êtes-vous devenu une liste
de droite et je ne suis je ne suis pas
apolitique je n'ai jamais dit que
j'étais apolitique et si je suis
candidat c'est bien que je fais de la
politique je n'ai prétendu que notre
mouvement de verre avenir était une
liste sans étiquette et je le réaffirme
aujourd'hui alors vous évoquez une
alliance ne s'agit pas d'une à l'iran
les sillons vous avez évoqué le terme
d'alliance et j'étais attentif
il s'agit en réalité d'une adhésion des
deux autres listes qui se sont désistés
et qui ont décidé de se retrouver dans
la liste sans étiquette qui accueillait
déjà des gens de
gauche de droite du centre ou sans
marquage et puis c'est une évolution
naturelle
ils ont accepté d'adhérer à mon
mouvement à mon programme qui n'a pas
évolué d'une virgule et donc je continue
de porter ce mouvement politique sans
étiquette rassembleur et fédérateur
florent sainte fare garnot vous vous
avez dit
les masques tombent est ce que ça veut
dire que vous considérez qu'il y avait
des masques avant cette union
oui très clairement d'abord je crois que
la première des choses c'est qu'au soir
du premier tour nous sommes en tête
largement en tête avec 8 de plus de 12
points avance sur nos concurrents et en
position de l'emporter
c'est une première chose il ya aussi un
message qui a été adressé par les
français au gouvernement et je pense
qu'il est important qu'ils soient
entendus
localement à nevers très clairement les
masques sont tombés à droite
après tout une campagne de premier tour
sur laquelle pendant laquelle elle a été
dit par monsieur thuriau et son équipe
que jamais au grand jamais il ne ferait
alliance avec quiconque étant troupe
attachés à leur indépendance
et surtout pas avec la droite ils ont
fait alliance et fusionner avec elle les
masques tombent et je dois dire que je
suis réellement choqués je suis devant
vous porter aussi des messages du
message des neversois
ils se sentent floués beaucoup d'entre
eux se sentent trompés dans leur
confiance donnée au premier tour parce
qu'il était sincèrement convaincu qu'il
s'agissait d'une liste de gauche et
compte tenu de ce qui ce passe je crois
véritablement qu' il y a en l'occasion
quelque chose autour du respect des
électeurs et la versoix qui
malheureusement n'a pas été tenue sauf
derrière votre position on va dire entre
entre ce qu'on vient d'entendre je je
savoure d'abord notre notre victoire la
victoire d'être présent au deuxième tour
le front national c'est une percée
intéressante et importante
hanover et puis je savoure également ce
revirement ce chavirement de cette liste
apolitique sans étiquette aucune
et là aussi effectivement on est obligé
de faire le même constat avec florent
sainte fare garnot une liste apolitique
masqué qui avance avec des convictions
finalement très minces qui sont dépassés
très rapidement par une ambition une
petite ambition une petite revanche
peut-être et qui se retrouve au deuxième
tour avec toute une kyrielle de liste de
tic est politique du modem en passant
par lui dénient jusqu'à l'ump la plus
dure est donc moi j'observe ça avec un
certain sourire et je trouve que c'est
quand même assez culotté de la part de
denis thuriau que de se présenter ici ce
soir alors que le 15 février
sur ce plateau même il disait ne pas
avoir les contraintes des autres partis
politiques en en question qui étaient
donc présents sur ce plateau est
aujourd'hui le voici avec trois ou
quatre étiquette politique dans sa liste
il s'appelle réaction bien sûr que mais
ses adversaires concurrents en tout cas
sont décidément mal entendants et je
réaffirme haut et fort que je suis
indépendant que c'est chez avocat je
suis un homme libre je suis un homme
indépendant je le revendique et le
mouvement devait ramener resterez en or
du parti socialiste pendant longtemps
denis therriault donc quand florent
sainte fare garnot dit vous étiez une
liste de gauche est ce que c'est parce
qu'un certain nombre de gens de nevers
ont entendu monsieur christophe gaillard
était aussi membre du parti socialiste
serait d'ailleurs le parti socialiste
sera présent sur vous rassure il semble
voilà donc je suis assez surpris mais ça
ne m'étonne pas de ne pas vouloir
regarder les choses en face
vous savez
front national parle de façon méprisant
de notre mouvement qui reste je le
rappelle indépendant et c'est une
adhésion
ce n'est pas une alliance une adhésion
c'est différent je n'ai pas des tickets
sur mon affiche les deux mouvements qui
se sont désistés ont adhéré à notre
programme je ré ainsi sans étiquetage
dessus ils ont apporté sur notre liste
chacun la tête de liste plus eu quatre
colistiers c'est une et les électeurs le
savent
pardonnez-moi les électeurs le service
est le leader de la liste ump qui vient
chez vous c'est pas c'est pas une
personne année quelle est la difficulté
j'avais des gens dans mon moule qui
était de droite qui était de gauche et
quand les gens voter au premier tour ils
ont voté pour une liste sans étiquette
avec des gens de droite de gauche du
centre qui ont accepté d'enlever ces
sectarisme pour se retrouver derrière un
programme
je suis rappellerai à monsieur florent
sainte fare garnot que son parti le
parti socialiste a soutenu assoute une
liste de monsieur barbier à la machine
une liste ouverte avec des personnes de
l'ump je rappellerai puisque nous sommes
à dijon que monsieur rebsamen a dans sa
10 des gens du modem je vois pas où est
la difficulté
moi par contre je continue je continue à
être sans étiquette et vous savez
j'entends bien que c'est quelque chose
de nouveau
il faut que les partis politiques se
posent les vraies questions pourquoi il
ya tant d'abstentions et pourquoi il y a
de moins en moins d'adhérents à leur
parti florent sainte fare garnot je veux
dire des choses très simples lui parler
avec mon coeur tout le monde sait très
bien que cette alliance de deuxième tour
est une alliance qui a trompé la
confiance donnée par les neuf et reçoit
et on peut dire ce qu'on veut on peut
raconter le film dans tous les sens
aucun discours aucune rhétorique ne
pourra faire que ce qui est ne soit pas
et tout simplement il y a eu des
déceptions il y a eu ce sentiment de
tromperie et c'est violent pour nos
électeurs pour les concitoyens qui se
sont déplacés aux urnes et je crois que
dans une période de crise singulièrement
où la démocratie est en danger
avec la montée des populismes 7 ce choix
alors qu'il était possible de garder
votre cohérence et serait lui-même une
certaine élégance et une certaine
noblesse
le fait de vous éloigner de ce que vous
avez dit
aux gens qui vous ont fait confiance est
un acte violent est une chose très
évidente c'est que comment voulez vous
sérieusement que des gens qui ne sont
d'accord sur rien puisse demain gérer la
ville ensemble
personne n'y croit un seul instant et
tous les discours de la terre ne
pourront pas changer ce que les neuf et
reçoit qui sont des gens intelligents
qui appelle simplement à ce qu'on les
respecte pense de ce sujet c'est
monsieur florent sainte fare garnot vous
estimez avoir fait un score formidable
vous avez perdu énormément de voix en
six ans vous ne fait pas l'unanimité
cette liste au total six se sont
présentés à vos côtés ça prouve qu'il
n'ya véritablement plus d'adhésions même
l'adhésion culturel ou socialisme à nos
verres je réaffirme puisque vous avez du
mal à entendre que mon programme reste
le même et qui n'a pas changé et que je
ne trahis personne je suis la propriété
de personne
en revanche innové reçoit se retrouvent
et je peux aussi vous dire qu'en
revenant à dijon vous savez nos verts
dijon ce n'est pas simple on a le temps
de regarder
merci aujourd'hui les deux concurrents
qui m'accompagne sur ce plateau faut une
campagne de caniveau affichant sur les
listes officielles sur l'affichage
officiel ce qui est interdit
leurs propres affiches de dénigrement et
j'ai énormément de retours de gens de
gauche de jean du parti socialiste qui
sont écoeurés et qui estime que vous
n'avez pas le monopole de la gauche et
qui estime que vous n'avez pas le
monopole de la démocratie et je crains
que vous ayez tendance à confondre qu'à
partir du moment où on n'est pas
d'accord avec vous on est de droite
c'est pas ça à la réalité des choses la
vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui les gens en
ont assez
assez de ce sectarisme qui les a perdus
et qui a perdu nevers donc je propose
autre chose pas une surprise mais un
espoir qui est la résultante de l'écouté
des autres oui moi je voudrais revenir
sur l'engagement denis thuriau et c'est
vrai que au départ j'avais trouvé
l'initiative on va dire assez douces
assez séduisante
une liste sans étiquette qui allait
faire chemin seul pour recueillir un
certain nombre de suffrages et notamment
les plus déçus des partis politiques
traditionnels
sauf que aujourd'hui moi je me pose un
certain nombre de questions
un certain nombre de questions
concernant la gouvernance et demain si
nevers passé à droite avec la liste de
monsieur thuriau jeudi il y aurait pour
moi et pour les noeuds vers soi aucun
changement n'est vraiment aucun
changement puisque
la liste de monsieur thuriau comprend
des personnes qui ont fait partie de
l'opposition au conseil municipal de
nevers et qui n'ont absolument rien
apporté si ce n'est leur leur incapacité
à s'opposer justement au conseil
municipal à la liste de florent sainte
fare garnot aujourd'hui la liste
sortante
donc je crois qu'il ya rien du tout de 9
et c'est vrai que la démarche paraissait
intéressante était séduisante au départ
aujourd'hui de faire cette coalition une
espèce de coalition de circonstance
c'est vraiment la droite la gauche
associés on n'y comprend plus rien c'est
l'amalgamme la plus totale en tout cas
ce que je moi je constate c'est
qu'effectivement le poids le plus
important c'est que demain s'ils donnent
iturrioz était aux manettes de nevers ce
serait vraiment ingérable une ville
ingérable parce que on ne pourra jamais
géré municipalité avec des convictions
de gauche et des convictions de droite
qui sont tout ça c'est pas me cible il
ya un gros problème de gouvernance et il
faut bien le rappeler aux nouvelles soit
je crois que c'est une tromperie
manifeste et 1
comment dirais-je sont des mercenaires
de la politique et donc moi je peux pas
accepter cette position aujourd'hui donc
que ce soit la gauche ou la droite ici
il y aura aucun changement absolument
aucun messieurs les représentants des
partis politiques arrêtez de prenez vos
bannières et réveillez vous les neuf et
reçoit en ôta c'est les français en ont
assez de sectarisme qui ne les mène pas
rien ne le sont plus aujourd'hui ils se
sont associés
60 associé ne seront pas là dit se sont
associés s'en séparer police n'ont pas
démissionné paul il porte aujourd'hui le
programme on compare données nous mais
c'est difficile à comprendre
je veux tout ce qui est doux et vous
savez l'utopie c'est ce qui n'a pas
encore été essayé c'est seulement cela
donc il va faire passer à autre chose il
ya aussi des convictions donc on imagine
que guillaume maillard que philippe
cordier n'ont pas abandonné leurs
convictions en allant rejoint ce
mouvement c'est qu'ils les ont
abandonnés pour ce projet qui est un
projet local ne verra venir ne s'engage
pas en politique nationale donc nous
sommes sur un terrain et vous savez pour
diriger une ville comme la veille a pas
besoin d'être de droite et de gauche et
je m'étonne qu'on souhaite me le donner
des leçons de gouvernance quand on voit
ce qu'a fait le front national des
villes qu'il a dirigé pendant des années
on connaît le résultat
quand on voit également les difficultés
entre les communistes et les verts qui
ne s'entendent pas et d'ailleurs à la
région à dijon les verts et notamment
monsieur sejeau qu'il soleil de monsieur
sainte fare garnot s'est opposé à la
subvention pour le bol d'or dans la
nièvre
c'est à dire qu on torpille une fois de
plus l'économie les verts étaient contre
le projet du centre aquatique à nevers
falloir aussi qu'on m'explique annoncent
avoir vraiment qu'une élection dans une
élection c'est un moment de vérité
voilà et qu' on ne peut pas dire à la
fois aux 9 et reçoit je suis de gauche
je mène une démarche indépendante et
entre les deux tours faire exactement le
contraire et on ne peut pas comme je
viens de l'entendre à l'instant
prétendent que les leaders de droite qui
ont rejoint cette liste de droite
- abandonner leurs étiquettes et leur
engagement partisan ce qui est
factuellement faux et que tout le monde
peut vérifier par ailleurs c'est quand
même sidérant moi qui débat avec l'ump
et lui dédie depuis plusieurs années
même si je ne suis pas d'accord je les
respecte est ce que j'entends à
l'instant c'est qu'ils auraient accepté
deux comme des crêpes passer sous la
férule autoritaire d'un mouvement qui
s'est imposé dans les six mois et qui a
fait seulement 23%
oui la démocratie dont tous la
connaissance que vous marans et ça pose
dans les six mois car les vacances et
les électeurs de l'ump et de l'udf
de tout cela ils ont eux aussi besoin de
se sentir représentés alors maintenant
je devrais sur le fond intervenir tous
les jours
le maire que je suis prend des décisions
politiques
lorsque je fais en sorte que le quotient
familial s'applique dans les restaurants
scolaires pour que tous aient accès
quelle que soit leur situation
financière et sociale à ce service
public
c'est une décision politique quand je
fais en sorte que la résidence pour
personnes âgées
daniel benoit propose un service médical
de très grande qualité à faible coût
c'est une décision politique et nous
sommes dans ce deuxième tour
la seule liste de gauche qui a gardé son
cap qui est crédible et cohérente et si
j'entends vos adversaires vous
fonctionnez aussi un système de clan
socialiste qu'il faut faire tomber un
système qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cette attaque
pourquoi vous seriez secteur notamment
bah écoutez si j'ai sans doute beaucoup
de défauts enfin c'est comme tout le
monde je pense que la première des
vertus en politique c'est d'être capable
de chercher à progresser en permanence
mais s'il ya un défaut que je n'ai pas
c'est d'être sectaire les neuf et reçoit
le savent tuer un homme ouvert un homme
de dialogue
notre liste accueille les verts pour la
première fois ce qui est un signe de
régénération de nouveautés à gauche et
très au delà de la gauche je dialogue
avec tous les noeuds vers soi je suis le
maire de tous les navires soient et
demain avec leur confiance je
continuerai de l'être on va peut-être à
voler oui je voulais revenir aussi sur
la position politique du front national
par rapport à mes deux compétiteurs
c'est vrai qu'on connaît mon engagement
par rapport et on l'a on l'a vu vous
l'avez remarqué lors du premier tour
c'est vrai qu'avec le parti socialiste
et cette liste d'union de la gauche
nous avons des divergences profondes et
un vrai clivage qui existent évidemment
vous l'avez remarqué tout le monde l'a
vu au moins si je veux reconnaître
quelque chose ne serait-ce qu'une
qualité
hamon compétiteurs à florent sainte fare
garnot c'est que cette ligne il la tient
il respecte ses engagements il suit
françois hollande c'est évidemment je
suis pas je suis vraiment contre cette
position et je je le déplore mais ils
respectent cette ligne quelle ne fut pas
ma surprise de découverts au soir du
deuxième tour
cette coalition
le soir du premier tour pardon cette
coalition ces alliances et qui sont pour
moi qui représente qui résonne comme une
forme de prostitution politique de la
part de l'ump de lui dit accepter par
monsieur thuriau ça c'était vraiment
vraiment très choquant et je pense que
pour on a vraiment humiliée les
électeurs qui s'étaient rangés derrière
cette liste a redonné ma carrière mais
je comprends ce que vous dites donc
sujet denis therriault mais on
al'impression vu de l'extérieur vous
posez quasiment en alliés de florent
sainte fare garnot tous c'est pas du
tout on connaît on connaît nos
divergences et elles sont profondes
nous sommes irréconciliables il ya aucun
problème sur le fond
par contre je dis que ne peut pas
tromper les électeurs de cette manière
et qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir réparer
il faudrait parce que des excuses et se
retirer c'est vraiment très grave ce qui
s'est passé c'est très choquant je crois
que le front national défend une ligne
une ligne qui tient une ligne que je
respecte j'ai déposé ma liste seul le
lendemain du premier tour parce qu on
est toujours sur cette même ligne
et c'est vrai que malgré nos divergences
malgré notre opposition très forte
il y a quelque chose qui peut se
ressemblent et chez florent sainte fare
garnot avec le front national c'est
contient cette ligne et on la respecte
bien sûr avec les divergences qu'on
connaît sur la personne de mon
compétiteurs mais je ne laisserai pas un
instant personne supposer que nous
puissions nous ressembler en quoi que ce
soit suis un républicain qui marque le
terrain des valeurs de respect
individuelle et qui à chaque instant de
mon engagement politique lutte contre
l'extrême droite réagir par rapport à
cela parce que quand j'entends mes deux
autres concurrents se porter en donneur
de leçons parce qu'ils représentent des
partis politiques indiquant que ma liste
sans étiquette est grave parce qu'elle
recueille des gens de droite et de
gauche c'est la différence qui enrichit
qui permet d'avancer il faudrait
peut-être le considérer un jour mais je
suis assez sidéré d'entendre que je
fasse des excuses
les excuses je ne ferai pas aux
électeurs qui m'ont fait confiance et ça
constitue un quart des lectorats je
conçois que ça gêne mes contradicteurs
qui se rejoignent là dessus subitement
simplement ce qui est grave qu'elle
était grave à nos verres
c'est la présence d'une personne et aux
nazis sur la liste du front national et
je pense qu'on en a parlé on a beaucoup
parlé
ce qui est grave c'est quand monsieur
gaillard a attaqué attaqué le grand père
de florent sainte fare garnot dont je ne
veux rien savoir et je suis le seul à
avoir pris la défense parce que j'ai dit
que je n'acceptais pas qu'on attaque un
homme
j'en étais mal le mal desservis sur le
retour parce que je fais aussi l'objet
aujourd'hui du parti socialiste d'attac
à titre personnel et c'est fort
regrettable
voilà ce qui est grave dans la campagne
de nos verres au ministère on parle a
découvert qu'elle était comme
admiratrice de canton quand on fait de
la politique pour se retenir puisque
vous nous aviez dit que vous
l'emmèneriez entre les deux on n'a
malheureusement pas pu le faire
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu fusion nous on
est restés droits dans nos bottes il
malheureusement on ne le savait pas
puisque éventuellement on aurait pu
fusionner avec une autre liste
on ne le savait pas au moment vous l'a
dit par contre ce que ce que je relève
c'est quand même un peu un peu fort je
vois monsieur thuriau qui me dit voilà
sur notre liste évidemment sur les trois
listes on peut dire qu'il y a des
candidats un peu malheureux jeux les
relevés gelée soulignait et je
m'aperçois également qu'en regardant un
peu sur la liste de monsieur thuriau
qu'on retrouve une personne qui s'était
engagé au front national qui avait signé
une lettre d'engagement et qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui sur la liste de
monsieur thuriau donc je crois qu'on a
aussi tous sur nos listes une optimisons
noir malheureusement allez on va avancer
pour terminer les regards dire sur
l'expression candidat malheureux
je crois qu'il y en a deux qui sont très
malheureux en ce moment c'est monsieur
martin a et monsieur mon toiles la
représentant de l'ue des îles l'ump qui
se sont vus remercier violemment entre
les deux tours parlez pas à leur place
pour pouvoir pour que la liste puissent
fusionner c'est ce que voulait dire avec
pour être tout à fait clair pour nous
téléspectateurs
allez on va vous dire un petit peu à vos
propositions pour lui parce qu'on a
envie d un tweet
demandait d'ailleurs pendant l'émission
dix ans quand est-ce qu'on passe au fond
des propositions pour la ville de nevers
et ses habitants si on ne devait
finalement ne retenir qu'un élément très
concrète vos programmes qui vous
différencie
qu'est ce que vous vous mettriez en
avant je lui rends sainte fare garnot on
s'est parfois l'emploi priorité numéro
un du mandat que je sollicite la part
des navires soit nous avons déjà des
succès économiques avec l'entreprise
selmi 150 salariés qui ont vu leurs
emplois sauvés grâce au travail que nous
avons engagé les élus et le chef
d'entreprise et dans le mandat qui vient
je souhaite faire de l'agglomération le
fer de lance du développement économique
parce que je considère avec tous les
nommés reçoit que l'emploi c'est
désormais le premier objet d'intérêt
général et le premier besoins des
habitants
il s'agit pour nous au fond d'inventer à
travers l'agglomération un chemin de
développement nouveau en misant sur la
filière bois en misant sur l'innovation
en soutenant les entreprises locales
chaque jour en misant aussi sur la
filière numérique parce que nous sommes
proches de paris et que nous avons une
boucle numérique et donc au fond ce qui
est l'essentiel pour moi c'est une
conviction très profonde et des combats
sur lesquels j'ai les premiers résultats
déjà et je veux aller plus loin pour
l'univers soir c'est l'emploi qu'est ce
qui vous sépare le plus de vos opposants
le futur you qu'est ce que vous voulez
mettre ces j'ai du mal à comparer que le
programme du front national parce qu'il
va pas bon moi j'ai pas d'étiquette
front national n'a pas de programme soit
un peu plus embêtant et mon
contradicteur en face monsieur sainte
fare garnot n'a pas de résultat c'est
encore plus embêtant donc moi ce qui
nous sépare bien évidemment c'est
l'économie c'est la loire et je suis
atterré d'entendre que désormais la
priorité du parti socialiste c'est
l'emploi fallait peut-être si
l'intéressé avant fallait peut-être s'y
intéressaient depuis une vingtaine
d'années aujourd'hui la population de
nos verts est la même qu'en 1954 trente
six mille habitants voyez l'évolution 60
ans aujourd'hui
aucune industrie où est implantée à
nevers et l'entreprise c'est le nid a
été sauvé nos pattes par monsieur sainte
fare garnot mais par des parlementaires
de la nièvre aujourd'hui à nevers on est
obligé d'aller en camionnette auprès des
ministères du gouvernement rappelait
notre existence
les 150 emplois sauvés on oublie tout ce
qu'on a perdu
donc ce que nous voulons
faire nous parce que c'est au niveau de
l'agglomération de te va se passer la
compétence économique c'est au niveau de
l'agglomération
c'est la première fois que les électeurs
vont élire leurs conseillers
communautaires au suffrage universel
c'est non pas attendre les emplois mais
les les chercher et voyez je ne suis pas
élu encore mais j'ai déjà fait ces
démarches
j'ai déjà rencontré la plupart des
maires de l'agglomération qui nous font
confiance et qu'ils n'attendent qu'une
chose c'est que nos verres change parce
que nos verres et dans le marasme et
savent très bien que si l'équipe
actuelle qui est quasiment la même repas
ça sera la même chose je suis allé en
chercher une entreprise qui est implanté
en chine les 8000 salariés dans le monde
qui me dit moi si l'équipe socialiste
repas je ne viens pas sinon je choisis
mon siège social je le fais à nevers je
suis en contact avec un ancien grand
champion du tour de france qui sera
notre ambassadeur et je vais faire de
nos vers la ville du cycle parce qu'il
existe le look cycle qui serait tout à
fait favorable à développer et bien
évidemment ce credo et toutes les villes
qui souhaitent s'en sont sortis sur un
plan économique sont des villes qui ont
déterminé un axe alors bien évidemment
il ya d'autres projets sera un retour au
dessus me permettent le cas quand même
été beaucoup plus important sur nos
verts qu'elle est maintenant et ils le
souhaitent de leur devenir mais dans
certaines conditions
concernant les le programme je crois que
le programme du front national du
rassemblement bleu marine
tout le monde le connaît il ya eu des
adaptations locales qui ont été faites
selon le contexte de 2 9 heures et
aujourd'hui personne ne le ne le rejette
bien au contraire ce programme mais je
crois que c'est quand même fallait c'est
moi sourire laissez moi rire quand même
un peu lorsque denis thuriau parle de
mon programme
moi je vois aujourd'hui une liste avec
trois programmes différents qui se range
derrière un programme derrière un
catalogue un peu fourre tout où les
propositions ne sont pas chiffrés ou les
propositions sont complètement alors les
boeufs les nôtres elles sont simples en
termes de fiscalité je crois qu'on a
fait une proposition choc qui était ce
qui me marque le plus il ya la fiscalité
liée à l'immigration personne n'en parle
ni la gauche ni la droite
ce soir personne ne parle de
l'insécurité et personne n'en parle et
donc nous on en parle vous connaissez
bien le programme du front national en
la matière personne ne parle de l'europe
également dans assez peu dans ces
élections municipales pour tout vous
dire et c'est pour ça qu'on vous
provoque la flore vous l'avez remarqué
la dernière fois je crois que j'ai une
petite revanche à prendre encore à votre
dernière question concernant l'europe et
l'économie sociale et solidaire
puisque vous savez qu avec florian
philippot je souhaite développer une
aile sociale au sein du front national
est convaincant jour pas du tout venant
vous m'aviez posé cette question et
dernière fois j'avais pas le temps de
répondre pour les gens qui nous avaient
pas regarder dans ce contexte la liste
effectivement vous avez fait remarquer
solidaire et subventions européennes
c'était pas le coeur du programme dont
vous êtes passionné par le vin soyez
passionné par l'europe et vous verrez
que nos propositions elles sont
cohérentes
elles sont cohérentes bien sûr avec
l'europe puisque on ne veux pas rejeter
le rock on ne veut pas faire la chasse
aux sorcières on veut simplement la
changer cette europe savez c'est un peu
comme le communisme à la fin du
communisme on nous disait mais il faut
en rajouter une louche et chaque fois il
faut plus de communisme et puis on a vu
la chute du communisme
vous voulez parler de programme et aucun
problème on va parler programme va
parler parce que je j'entends et nous et
bâtons et jets le respect de mes
compétiteurs
d'abord sur la question économique nous
avons sauvegardé 150 emplois c'est
l'entreprise selmi il ya 25 postes qui
seront créés dans les douze mois grâce à
la dynamique son carnet de commandes ce
combat je les mener personnellement avec
le soutien d'autres élus et c'est un
combat que j'ai engagé personnellement
nous avons le même résultat sur
l'entreprise centre pharma qui se
développent de très belle façon
elle est notamment est là dans son
carnet de commandes l'occitane qui est
une marque est bien connue et cette
entreprise 55 salariés est en train de
grandir
il ya quinze créations de postes qui
sont prévus dans les douze mois nixon
une entreprise qui intervient sur des
échangeurs thermiques sont des pièces
industrielles qui sont présentes dans le
domaine de la chimie et de la
pétrochimie qui vient de se créer à
nevers il ya douze mois avec un homme
extrêmement compétent parce qu'il vient
de d'alfa laval spirale à nevers et qui
a déjà créé 15 postes qui a des carnets
de commandes qui vont nous emmener vers
une centaine de créations d'emplois dans
les 18 mois
voilà ce que nous faisons c'est à
l'agglomération de demain avec la liste
que je mène si je suis élu maire
dimanche prochain alors j'entends
d'abord je trouve qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'être agressif vous indiquez
que nous n'avons jamais rien fait je
viens apporter la preuve du contraire
vous avez dit avec j'ai trouvé une
certaine agressivité ici ou là
j'avais découvert que la loire coulé à
nevers tout voilà simplement quelques
semaines j'aimerais un peu plus
sérieusement dire que nous sommes
l'équipe municipale actuelle et je suis
le maire qui a lancé la politique de
réappropriation de la loire avec le
nouveau quai des mariniers et
l'opération un air de loire donc un peu
de respect aussi de respect des idées de
chacun et un mot tout de même n'est pas
interdit aussi de à l'occasion avec
respect mais tout de même de dire
certaines choses vous n'avez pas
d'expérience politique vous n'avez pas
encore exercé de mandat aucun aucune
expérience et il me semble que de dire
au soir qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui à
quelques jours du deuxième tour que l'on
a dans la manche une entreprise chinoise
de 8000 salariés qui viendraient par
hélicoptère à nevers ça n'est pas
sérieux et je pense que pour les
responsabilités que chacun d'entre nous
brigue devant les new versoix je pense
qu'il vaut mieux pratiquer à la fois la
vérité et un certain sens de la solidité
des choses et du sérieux pour ma
carrière à 1 306 je ne dis pas promesses
en l'air je dis simplement que dans le
débat qui nous oppose la question de la
vérité la crédibilité est posée donc je
voudrais rappeler si vous aimez en
question quand même d'accord parce que
c'est très révélateur de l'intérêt de
l'équipe municipale en place sur
l'économie j'ai accompagné
personnellement auprès de monsieur
florent sainte fare garnot des
entreprises ou des commerçants qui
voulaient se développer créer de
l'emploi et on m'a dit mais je vais vous
aider il demandait pas d'argent et
demandé une aide logistique une aide
d'implantation sur ce fameux site
colbert qui est à moitié désert qui
devait être selon monsieur boulot d'un
grand centre économique et on m'a dit
bah oui je vais mettre mes services de
sion à barco vous pouvez rencontrer le
promoteur ces personnes là j'étais
accompagné vous savez ou chez le
mandataire judiciaire parce qu'elles ont
déposé le bilan parce qu'on ne s'en
n'est pas intéressé je regrette que vous
méprisez des entreprises qui veulent
venir à nos verres je ne donne quoi mais
pas 8000 emplois demain jean promet
quelques uns puis c'est une entreprise
dont le concurrent principal enfance à
1000 emplois donc ça veut dire que c'est
un vecteur de développement et voyez
j'ai pas attendu
j'ai pas besoin d'école il n'y a pas
d'école de mer y a pas d'école d'élus on
vous a pris on vous a mis à nos verts
c'est un parachutage les nous versons en
ont assez des parachutages je suis né
vers soi ce n'est pas une légitimité
en soi en tout cas c'est une
connaissance et un amour de ma ville
qu'on ne peut pas m'enlever je pense une
chose nul besoin d'être aussi agressif
je suis pas là si jeu convaincant je
vais terminer un jeu mais vous
convaincre l'anversois de ce que vous
n'avez pas chevet des années savent et
roger conscient mais on prendra votre
personne impliquée mais je me porte sur
la création d'une qualité de sur
laquelle sur la question de l'ancrage à
nevers lorsque le d'abord permettez moi
de vous dire que pierre bérégovoy qui
est je crois pour tous les 9 et reçoit
quelqu'un d'important et dont la mémoire
est respecté dans l'action de mr l'est
tout autant
permettez-moi de vous rappeler
simplement ceci il n'était pas né à
nevers
ça fait dix ans que je vis à nevers que
j'aime cette ville que je lui donne
chaque jour de ma vie travail de
l'intérêt général
la mission de mer et donc je ne vous
laisserai pas sur ce plan m en cause mon
engagement est une chose l'amour de nos
verres la première des choses l'amour
des noeuds vers soi c'est de leur dire
la vérité et de respecter la confiance
qu'ils nous donnent c'est ce que je
respecte
c'est ce que je respecte je voudrais
juste répondu j'attends et je savoure de
me positionner en arbitre si vous voulez
parce que je voudrais revenir sur un
point qui est important le point de
l'économie et de l'emploi qui a été
développé par sainte fare garnot du
parti socialiste aujourd'hui les
chiffres du chômage sont sortis
malheureusement bon c'est un échec
cinglant pour la politique est menée par
le parti socialiste
je voudrais lui rappeler ça et puis je
voudrais rappeler également quand on
parle ici ce soir il faudrait rétablir
un certain nombre de vérités la vérité
selon laquelle ben de mes deux
compétiteurs aucun n'a encore été élu à
ce jour moi je l'étais en 2008 sur une
île sur une liste sans étiquette puisque
j'étais tête de liste sans étiquette une
vraie liste sans étiquette qui était
adaptée à la situation locale puisqu'il
s'agissait d'une petite ville et que ce
positionnement se prêtait bien et je
pense qu'ils auraient continué leur et
persévérer dans sa démarche il aurait
été élu et demain moi je peux je vous le
garantis c'est mon pronostic
et il s'avéra vrai au soir du deuxième
tour denis thuriau sera le responsable
de la victoire du parti socialiste à 9
heures
premièrement et puis deuxièmement il
sera le responsable de l'échec de la
mise à mort de l'ump de lui des ânes ou
vert pour très longtemps
voilà pour l'économie bon il faut quand
même que je rappelle quelque chose quand
on parle de la chine
je trouve ça assez intéressant que de se
découvrir des talents économistes de
développeurs d'entreprise et s'est
subitement lorsqu'il s'agit de de faire
des propositions dans une élection
municipale
moi j'ai une entreprise en chine j'ai
pas attendu les élections municipales
pour développer une entreprise en chine
en 2011 et une entreprise qui a bien
fonctionné que j'ai revendu un groupe
chinois avec lequel j'ai un partenariat
on est très amis on se côtoie
régulièrement et sont des gens qui sont
effectivement venus à nevers je crois
pas je crois pas pour prêter je ne prête
pas du tout de crédit à ce que ce
qu'affirme monsieur thuriau vous savez
quand un chinois vient visiter une ville
il s'adresse d'abord aux élus locaux ou
à quelqu'un qu'il connaît n'est pas à
quelqu'un qui est en campagne c'est
impossible quand on connaît le
tempérament des chinois des décideurs
des investisseurs ce n'est pas possible
donc aujourd'hui qu'on ne vienne pas
nous raconter ses salades
je veux bien qu'on fasse des salades
dans une liste un mixage une sauce un
peu indigeste mais qu'on ne vienne pas
me raconter ce genre de choses
concernant la chine parce que c'est
vraiment déplacé et maladroit pour le
coup avoue simplement j'espère que dans
quelques jours vous aurez lequel on voit
que c'est pas des salades parce que si
les novae reçoit me font confiance
cette entreprise a décidé les facultés
en allemagne s'appelle manoir reprise
est cesser voilà et s'implantera à
nevers je sais pas rosières lentilles
malheureuse un mot sur pierre bérégovoy
pour répondre à monsieur sainte fare
garnot c'était un homme qui était
respecté par tous moi je l' ai connu pas
vous j'ai pu échanger avec lui vous avez
trahi ex aux collaborateurs il est
respecté à nevers et je pense que s'il
revenait aujourd'hui voir sa ville il
serait terrifiée de voir dans l'état
dans laquelle elle se trouve enfin
permettez moi tout simplement parce que
pierre bérégovoy est important à nevers
c'est un homme qui réellement a marqué
la ville à la fois par ses réalisations
larissa grandeur morale sa dimension
politique et que vous puissiez vous vous
en prévaloir ne prévaut pas à la légère
avec dans votre liste saint désormais
dans votre liste
cas désormais avec les gens qui ont
attaqué très violemment très violemment
l'ump élu d ea ou leurs devanciers le
rpr et l'udf ont été les adversaires de
pierre bérégovoy
ils ont attaqués avec une extrême
violence ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
visent à la casse avec une extrême
violence
et je trouve assez déplacé que vous
puissiez aujourd'hui jouer avec sa
mémoire
vous n'êtes pas bon juge monsieur saint
thomas je ne juge pas mais je vous
demande de ne pouvait pas laisser passer
ce que j'ai je vends rien à dire de
respecter
voilà certaines choses moi aussi vous
l'oubliez en ce moment vos équipes
l'oubli en ce moment vu les saloperies
pardonnez moi qui sont en train d'être
mises et qui ont entraîné une plainte
pénale de ma part cet après midi je vous
le dis oui tout à fait le non respect de
l'affichage officiel
monsieur stéphane jean baptiste pour ne
pas citer est en train de coller sur nos
pages officielles ce qui est interdit
par la loi sur les propos tenus sur le
fait que j'aurais mis une association en
difficulté dont je ne suis plus le
président en 2007 et qui va qui allait
très bien lorsque je n'étais plus le
lorsque j'ai cessé ma présidence est
aujourd'hui un papier un torchon été
diffusées par les équipes socialiste
dans les différents quartiers de nevers
pas de chance le trésorier de cette
association c'est le mari de la numéro 2
de monsieur cinq soeurs regard de madame
martine carrillon-couvreur un autre une
autre de ces personnes c'est
effectivement monsieur billois le mari
d'une de vos co listière on essaye de
nous faire porter le chapeau de beaucoup
de choses mais je pense que le secteur
associatif le connaît et les gens qui le
portent ne s'y tromperont pas sinon ils
n'ont pas de contentieux on se trompe
parce qu on a l'impression que non non
je pense qu'il faut respecter les règles
ou si je suis un légaliste suis un
avocat
je respecte mes adversaires je parle
avec conviction pas l'agressivité
ne confondez pas c'est pas comme ça
quand je suis agressif voilà non mais
moi je veux pas rentrer dans ces
considérations
je pense que nous sommes là ce soir pour
les noeuds vers soi pour défendre des
idées pour défendre un projet je vois
beaucoup de violences beaucoup
d'agressivité
j'ai pas envie de me situer au même
niveau l'avait évoqué christophe
gaillard le thème de la fiscalité où
vous proposez une baisse de 30% la
pression fiscale ainsi je ne m'abuse
est-ce que c'est sérieux est ce que
c'est possible quand on sait que l'état
va également baisser ses dotations
non seulement c'est sérieux c'est
possible se réalise
ablé l'équipe en place l'équipe sortante
du parti socialiste l'a prouvé puisque
ont établi cette économie à 6 millions
d'euros sur l'ensemble de la mandature
ce que vient de faire florent sainte
fare garnot lors de la dernière
mandature il vient de faire la même
chose 6,6 millions d'euros d'économies
donc c'est tout à fait réalisable
d'une part parce que ça a déjà été fait
et qu'on peut le refaire et d'autre part
c'est que la politique que je souhaite
mettre en place est une politique
évidemment vous l'aurez compris
totalement différent de ce que fait le
parti socialiste aujourd'hui par exemple
rognant sur des budgets qui sont ceux de
la communication sur les budgets qui
sont ceux de des dotations aux
subventions par exemple en ayant un
contrôle très strict et régulier des
subventions qui sont distribués à des
associations sous forme d'oeuf c'est une
forme de clientélisme en quelque sorte
et à des associations contre lesquels je
m'oppose qui sont des associations
plutôt cultuelle par exemple voilà et
puis budget de la communication avec eux
c'est vrai un certain nombre d'abus à
nevers avec je les dis on avait fait une
petite étude en la matière sur le
magazine municipal qui comprend 70 80
pages selon les mois et qui a ville
constante et budget constant en france
pour des villes de taille similaire sont
en général des magazines qui font 20 ou
30 pages par exemple donc aujourd'hui on
a un véritable dépassement excessif du
budget communication à nevers et on a
plutôt ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
propagande pour le parti socialiste
essaie ça contre lequel je m'oppose moi
aujourd'hui demain pour baisser les
dépenses
je pense pas que ce soit nécessaire
d'avoir un ou deux chauffeurs pour se
promener d'un quartier à un autre à
nevers par exemple voyez il ya on
pourrait faire une liste non exhaustive
des dépenses qu'il faudrait réduire à
l'avenir lors de la prochaine mandature
denis thuriau si j'ai bien lu baissé de
trois points sur trois ans taxe
d'habitation taxes foncières
oui tout à fait et là dessus je rejoins
voyez que je sais reconnaître les bonnes
idées là où elles sont simplement c'est
moi qui l'avais poser en premier dans le
cadre de cette campagne sur nos réseaux
sociaux baissé de 3 fois la fiscalité un
point par an sur trois ans cela paraît
quelque chose de raisonnable aujourd'hui
nevers et dans le haut des taux
d'imposition est le plus haut et
l'équipe municipale sortante vous
regardez nous n'avons pas augmenté les
impôts évidemment le curseur a été mis
tout en haut dès le début il suffit de
le baisser nous sommes à + 3 points de
la moyenne nationale
qu'est ce qui le motive en matière de
taxe d'habitation nous sommes à plus de
5 points au-dessus de la moyenne
nationale sur la bo foncier caisse qui
le justifie et nous sommes alors je n'en
parle même pas sur le foncier non bâti
moyenne nationale 59% nous sommes à 95%
à 9 heures qu'est-ce qui le justifie
pour vous donner un exemple
produit par habitant inde vers 1640
euros bourges 1380 euros
moulin 1300 euros dépenses par habitant
à nos vers 1500 euros bourges 1140 euros
moulin 1290 euros oui je suis prêt si
vous voyez qu'on est dans le haut mais
dans le mauvais au pour nevers si on
veut faire revient de la population ça
commence par là et c'est aussi
l'économie
je complète dans un contexte où même on
sait que les baisses de dotations de
l'état aux communes vont être
extrêmement importante dans les années à
venir ce qui peut quand même rendre plus
difficile la baisse des impôts oui mais
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut si dans six
ans pour les prochaines élections
municipales on veut être trente mille
habitants laissons les choses telles que
et puis les gens s'en vont kit nevers
dans le meilleur des cas vous en
périphérie est aujourd'hui dans le pire
des cas sans vos complètement et je peux
vous assurer que dans le cadre de cette
campagne j'ai eu de nombreux messages de
gens qui nous disent voilà si le taux
d'imposition ne change pas nous
partirons aujourd'hui les biens
immobiliers ne se vendent plus à nevers
ou à des prix dérisoires donc il faut
commencer par cela
ça veut dire des économies ça veut dire
une meilleure gestion et moi j'entends
parce que je suis aussi quelqu'un qui a
une entreprise en tant qu'avocat avec un
cabinet d'avocats j'entends mettre du
mix et m'inspirer des bonnes idées dans
la pratique de gestion privée elle
n'entend pas mettre le public on peut
priver parce que nous avons besoin des
deux et dans mon mouvement dans ma liste
chez des personnes qui proviennent du
secteur public du secteur privé mais
rien qu'en cela je peux vous dire que
aujourd'hui j'entends des élus qui me
dit je me suis trompé
c'est pas grave ces noces ou dans le
privé vous ne vous trompez pas ou alors
en général c'est fatal florent sainte
fare garnot alors sur les impôts vous
aussi vous vous engagez à baisser les
impôts dans le courant de votre mandat
mais sans fixer vraiment vraiment tout
simplement pas par esprit de
responsabilité se dire que nous avons
pris l'orientation d'une baisse des
impôts elle sera tenue
nous avions dans
mandat qui se termine prix l'orientation
d'une stabilité des impôts ça a été
tenue ça a demandé 6 millions d'euros
d'économies ces économies ont été
réalisées
c'est un vraiment une oeuvre de réformes
internes de la ville absolument
considérable parce qu'être mère c'est
difficile cegid gérer véritablement une
entreprise publique de service public
qui suppose de la solidité des
compétences et un regard précis donc
cela a été réussi dans le contexte qui
vient à l'évidence à la fois pour le
pouvoir d'achat des noeuds vers soi et
pour l'attractivité de la ville il y as
besoin de baisser les impôts je veux
donner ce ses terres cet oxygène aux
habitants et en même temps vous l'avez
fort bien dit et cherchant temps les
compétiteurs passer cela sous silence
l'état dans le cadre du redressement des
finances publiques va baisser les
dotations de la ville c'est à dire
l'argent que l'état verse à notre
commune au vert pour rendre des services
ou non vers ce soit des villes les plus
aidés absolument et donc demain annoncé
des baisses d'impôts immédiates c'est le
cas de mes deux compétiteurs c'est
impossible concrètement sauf à dire mais
alors là j'aimerais qu'on me l'indiquent
quelles mesures concrètes seraient
appliquées quels services publics
fermerait est ce que c'est la maison de
la culture
c'est un million d'euros pourquoi pas
moi je m'y oppose fermement elle déploré
dijon la maison d'inculture mauvais
départ de l'agglomération pas les
dossiers l'an passé l'occasion de jeu
les gones et bien c'est l'occasion d'une
explication de texte pas reprocher à mes
compétiteurs de ne pas connaître les
dossiers mais éventuellement se mettre
en risque oui
l'agglomération a pris la compétence de
la maison de la culture effectivement
sauf que le financement de cette maison
de la culture reste municipal et sur les
dotations que l'agglomération nous verse
à nous la ville elle a retranché la part
qui finance la maison de la culture
donc c'est un financement effectivement
municipal revenons aux sujets sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat nous
baisserons les impôts dans le mandat
c'est impossible c'est pas sérieux
d'annoncer que ce sera fait tout de
suite il faut pour cela un retour de
croissance
donc je suis clair je suis crédible et
je dis la vérité alors une chose est de
faire l'effort sur les impôts
une autre est de parler du pouvoir
d'achat et en tant que maire
demain je prendrai des mesures et elles
ont été largement documentée dans cette
campagne dans notre programme pour le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la baisse du prix
de l'eau immédiatement c'est la mise en
place d'une mutuelle de santé qui
permettra grâce au soutien de la ville
qui négociera les prix de proposer en
moyenne 240 euros d'économie par an et
par foyer c'est considérable c'est
infiniment supérieur aux baisses
d'impôts qui sont proposés par mes
compétiteurs et c'est la mesure de
baisse du coût du chauffage pour 2000
logements 2000 logements ça représente
3000 habitants qui vont faire 30 %
d'économie sur leur chauffage
ça représente 300 euros par an et donc
avec des convictions avec une compétence
et une solidité
ce que je propose avec notre équipe
l'équipe de gauche à nevers c'est de
faire en sorte que réellement sur le
pouvoir d'achat
il y ait une amélioration et sans pour
cela
promettre des choses qui ne sont pas
tenables et dès le début du mandat
et dès le début du monde oui je suis
heureux que monsieur sainte fare garnot
et pris notre bonne option d'annoncer la
baisse de la fiscalité parce que s'y
était opposé et souvenez-vous de lors de
votre débat anneau vert il l'avait dit
que quand les choses iraient mieux sur
le plan de l'économie nationale il le
ferait puisque maver a été victime de la
mondialisation
alors je crois qu'il faut être sérieux
j'ai encore ses propos en tête je vous
l'assuré changé et c'est trés ni
l'expression oui non mais c'est très
intéressant de voir cousy cette volonté
moi je regrette que vous ne mettriez
surtout aux électeurs de la poudre aux
yeux comme le centre aquatique envoyé
une mutuelle à 20 euros est ce que c'est
un programme politique
vous le savez bien aujourd'hui la loi
impose aux employeurs de prendre en
charge une partie de la mutuelle de
leurs salariés
la plupart refusent parce qu'ils sont
déjà couverts par des choix qu'ils font
parce qu'il est très difficile au niveau
des contrats de groupe de convenir à
beaucoup là aussi c'est un leurre de
plus je peux vous assurer que les neuf
et reçoit aujourd'hui nous plus envie de
se faire duper sur la proposition de
cette mutuelle de groupe je crois
qu'elle est elle est proposée par le
front national qui développe aussi ce
genre de projet chez bompard chez ménard
par exemple du front national c'est une
proposition qui a été faite c'est une
proposition qui est faite d'ailleurs
dans d'autres petites communes du
département de la nièvre
donc là dessus on peut se rejoindre par
contre ce que j'entends ou concernant
des projets pharaoniques pour la piscine
de nouvelles c'est un sujet un sujet qui
a défrayé la chronique mais il faut
quand même en reparler non juste une
minute pour être un peu sérieux parce
que j'ai cru comprendre qu'il ya eu un
peu de nouveauté
ces derniers jours là dessus voilà il ya
deux positions qu'on peut être évoluer
en tout cas la mienne elle est toujours
constante elle est toujours la même
c'est toujours un projet qui est 7
millions et peut-être je crois
maintenant 10 millions moins cher que
les projets qui sont présentés par mes
compétiteurs aujourd'hui et tromper là
et et dont on reste toujours sur la même
ligne une piscine à 10 millions d'euros
environ qui se présentent sur nevers et
là vous voyez tout de suite on trouve 7
8 10 millions selon les projets
d'économies immédiates
voilà ça c'était important de le
rappeler il s'agit d'une piscine
modulable et non pas une piscine
extravagante pour cinquante soixante
mille personnes
florentin prague juste un mot pour
revenir sur cette proposition de
mutuelles de santé
c'est une proposition qui a été inventée
c'était l'année dernière par une commune
du vaucluse
c'est une commune divers gauche et c'est
une très belle idée qui est en train de
se développer l'idée très simple c'est
que comme un employeur qui peut à
travers un contrat de groupe
proposé en fait les mêmes services en
termes de couverture santé que ce qui
existe à des prix très élevés mais à des
prix beaucoup plus bas
grâce à la force du nombre lorsqu'on
négocie pour 200 ou 300 salariés
évidemment chacun d'entre eux dispose de
prix plus intéressants et bien il est
possible de le faire pour une commune et
donc demain en tant que maire avec la
volonté d'agir sur le pouvoir d'achat et
sur la santé de nos concitoyens je
négocierai un tel contrat qui permettra
effectivement en moyenne 240 euros
d'économie par an et par foyer et je ne
pense pas pour ma part que les neuf et
reçoit trouve que cela est que cela
c'est ridicule ou qu' on puisse le
balayer d'un revers de main un mot quand
même puisque alémanique on y passerait
pas la nuit mais sur ce projet de
piscine qui a l'air d'être au coeur de
la corbeille louis yvert
oui bien sûr qu'il est au coeur de l'été
passé moi je me souviens qu'au débat à
nos verts et l'ump et lui dit n'était
pas exactement sur la même position
alors vous voyez ce programme est
possible au dessus du parti socialiste
papier glacé il est simplement
raisonnable en papier recyclable dedans
il est marqué quoi il est marqué
comprend le temps et moi aussi j'en
beeson pas des députés dans trois ans
comme lui ça ne faire guère nos équipes
et nos verts parce que c'est le syndrome
mais on prend les gens mais méfions nous
quitte et puis on amer on sait pas trop
qui est sûrement pas celui que les gens
ont voulu donc moi je m'engage pour ma
ville et je m'engage à rester les six
ans de mon mandat donc je n'ai pas
besoin de pyramide pour se rappeler de
moi quand je serais parti alors c'est
pas compliqué déjà cette piscine ce
centre aquatique c'est un aveu du manque
d'anticipation et vous donner des leçons
monsieur sainte fare garnot parce que
vous êtes maire depuis quelques années
en disant que c'est vous qui savez tous
et pas les autres
vous donnez des sources du manque
d'ambition du manque d'anticipation et
si aujourd'hui on en est là c'est parce
que la municipalité actuelle n'a pas tu
su anticiper la fin d'un équipement
qu'on appelle la piscine des bords de
loire
et si on sait bien gérer sa ville comme
pour tous les équipements sportifs qui
sont en ruine chez nous et bien on
anticipons c'est la fin d'une piscine
donc on en prévoit une autre et puis
elle devrait être fait depuis des années
on n'en parlerait pas dans cette
campagne comme c'est un enjeu
aujourd'hui il est hors de question de
faire une piscine au zoo en zone
inondable en zone inondable pardon ça
coûte 3 millions d'euros en plus il faut
on n'a pas les moyens nos verts il faut
avoir un projet raisonnable et là dessus
je rejoins ce qu'a dit monsieur gaillard
à bourges par exemple a été rénové une
piscine bassins de 50 matchs au fait 9
millions d'euros
on peut tout à fait dans ces proportions
c'est dans la proportion de la capacité
de nos verres et des besoins de nos
verts puisqu'il ya d'autres piscines
existantes faut pas vouloir faire sa
piscine votre avec l'agglo et faire les
autres piscines
donc nous prendrons le temps quatre
millions d'euros ont été mis de côté par
le conseil municipal pour provisionner
nous offrir autre chose rénover le petit
théâtre par exemple ya des tas de
projets à faire référence à des regards
nous sur ce sujet la piscine après on
range les maillots de bain pour bien
skier
garneau a ajouté hier soir qu'il allait
enfin consulter les noeuds vers soirée
tous contents les vallées consulter
c'est moi je la chose nouvelle
quant aux faits à projets aux consultent
d'abord et au faisceau projet après on
consulte pas une fois qu'on est à deux
jours de l'élection du deuxième tour
c'est un peu tard allez la concertation
subitement oui alors peut-être d'abord
encore une fois des attaques
personnelles de faire ce que j'ai un
projet avec nous maître a précédemment
un rocher vous avez un projet sur un
plateau de télévision à l'instant que
j'allais partir donc à présent les
polichinelles vous à ce crédit serait ce
qu'avec sans doute le désir secret
qu'effectivement je pars pour vous
laisser la place mais moi je respecte
vous annoncer que je vais quitter nos
heures ça fait dix ans je viens à dire
que je me sens bien que j'y ai installé
ma famille voilà je serai maire à 100%
je ne cumulerait aucun mandat je ne
cumule pas et je ne cumulerait pas
demain je ne cumulerait pas non plus
d'activité professionnelle
ce qui n'est pas vrai de mes
compétiteurs et surtout je ne serai pas
candidat aux élections législatives en
j'aimerais laver ce type d'attaqué est
qu'on puisse parler effectivement des
projets je vois je vois pas l'utilité de
m'attaquer pense que c'est pas l'enjeu
d'une élection que d'attaquer un homme
ment sur la piscine donc l'anticipation
elle a été faite puisque j'ai lancé des
travaux de rénovation pour la piscine
des bords de loire
ceci étant dit cette piscine elle va
arriver en fin de vie chacun le sait
elle a 30 ans et plus même et il est
temps maintenant d'en construire une
nouvelle ya un besoin pour les scolaires
les enfants pour les sportifs pour les
adultes qui veulent tout simplement
aller nager ensuite sur l'agglomération
l'accord avec l'agglomération je vais
déjà obtenus elle a déjà à voter 7
millions d'euros de soutien à ce projet
ceci étant dit le projet que je présente
après des années de travail avec un
cabinet d'experts sur le sujet il se
trouve qu il que cette piscine ce projet
a fait l'objet d'un débat
moi je respecte le débat je respecte mes
contradicteurs et je respecte surtout
les noeuds vers soi qui m'ont dit
pendant cette campagne
votre projet nous intéresse mais on veut
en savoir plus et donc tout simplement
je vais ouvrir une concertation
après les élections pour donner toute
l'information rassurer ce projet ne
coûtera pas un centime fiscalement aux
habitants il n'y aura aucune difficulté
ni aucune expropriation
et nous prendrons ensemble les bonnes
décisions un mot sur les programmes sur
la jeunesse parce qu'on a eu des
questions notamment
je ne sais pas si on va les revoir sur
sur twitter est ce que vous vous assez
sympathique peut-être sur ce sujet nous
reste à les six minutes avant d'attaquer
les conclusions vos projets sur la
jeunesse on nous disait sur le twitt les
et les jeunes s'en vont voilà les jeunes
partent de nevers pour leur étaient
supérieurs et n'y reviennent pas quels
projets vous avez pour la jeunesse je
crois qu'il ya déjà un point positif
c'est que sur lequel tout le monde peut
s'accorder c'est que les trois
compétiteurs sont déjà beaucoup plus
jeunes ont rajeuni la classe politique à
nevers c'est déjà un premier point
positif pour les jeunes en direction des
jeunes
le deuxième c'est que effectivement je
crois que et là on va on peut reparler
du bilan du parti socialiste de nevers
c'est vrai que les jeunes ont été pour
ma part c'est un constat qui est partagé
je crois les jeunes ont été les grands
perdants de cette dernière mandature
puisque avec ce fameux clientélisme ce
système qui a été mis en place
les jeunes sont partis massivement de
nevers je crois par exemple qu'il y
avait des initiatives concernant
l'opposition à une certaine époque il
s'agissait de retenir les jeunes avec
notamment la première année de médecine
de fac de médecine à nevers c'est un
projet qui avait été rejetée parce que
c'est un projet qui était contraire à
l'idéologie socialiste et c'est un peu
regrettable
bien qu'il s'agissait d'une initiative
émanant de du rpr ou de l'ump à l'époque
je crois que c'était un projet
intéressant et je crois qu à nevers
aujourd'hui il faut redonner cette
dynamique
c'est vrai en créant peut-être cette
première année de fac
et puis il ya d'autres propositions aux
cibles sont intéressantes mais les
étudiants sont vraiment au centre de mes
préoccupations en tout cas c'est la
nouvelle on a loupé beaucoup de choses
et quand j'entends dire nevers a besoin
d'une piscine aujourd'hui je m'excuse
d'y revenir mais les jeunes ils vont
dans cette piscine nevers a besoin d'une
piscine depuis longtemps mais qui soit
raisonnable
alors pour en revenir à votre question
plus précise et celle de vos
téléspectateurs c'est important la
jeunesse c'est ce qui manquait n'a versé
j'ai un fils qui passent le baccalauréat
qui en rend reid veut envie de revenir
après ses études c'est moi qui suis là
depuis des générations du côté de mes
deux familles qui vais lui dire de ne
pas revenir mourir dans la nef si rien
ne change
voilà ce qui me motive dans ma démarche
aujourd'hui qui est sincère donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes une ville
avec 3000 étudiants pratiquement à
nevers ce que l'on ne sait pas ses
terres la deuxième ville de bourgogne a
prédit jean alors de très loin il y
avait des choses à faire et christophe
gaillard a raison je vous parlais de
sectarisme
bien sûr qu'il y en a parce que c'est il
faut lui rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar c'est un conseiller général de
droite qui est proposée une faculté de
médecine
ça a été refusé je me j'ai entendu dire
les socialistes d'hier c'est une idée de
gauche on ne la prend pas il faut
absolument s'en crée sur cette année
médecine pourquoi parce que ça nous
permettra aussi de travailler en lien
cas chu et de recevoir les internes en
fin de cursus et trouver un engagement
pour qu'ils restent réhabitée l'hôpital
pierre bérégovoy qui se désertifient
c'est un outil moderne où il ya donc de
moins en moins de médecins
ça veut dire s'intéresser à d'autres
formations haute que le post bac
la faculté droit ya que deux années ont
pour elles à l'augmenter ça veut dire
faire de la formation sur certains
métiers qui disparaissent comme la
boucherie nous sommes dans la région du
charolais par exemple dans la couverture
parce que tout le monde ne fait pas le
baccalauréat et des études post-bac faut
s'intéresser à tout le monde moi j'ai
rencontré des tas de jeunes j'entendais
monsieur sainte fare garnot de dire
mercredi à plein d'entreprises
j'ai rencontré des plats de jeunes
pleins de jeunes qui s'en vont toute la
semaine puis avec de la chance si rennes
le week-end voir leur famille et leurs
amis
on n'est pas capable de leur offrir de
l'emploi ça pose question oui je pense
est un enjeu très important
vraiment effectivement il ya un enjeu
nevers à une jeunesse que nous
souhaitons tous garder notre ville pour
qu'elle puisse amener son énergie son
regard sa capacité à créer et j'en suis
tout à fait le premier convaincu
alors comment faire d'abord vous avez
évoqué le fait que la ville de nevers
soit le deuxième pôle universitaire de
bourgogne
ce n'est pas le fait du hasard c'est le
fait de notre travail
la mairie effectivement et les
socialistes ne vous déplaise
nous avons réussi à doubler les
effectifs de l'isaf qui sont passées de
300 à 600 étudiants pendant le mandat
mon mandat de maire celui qui se termine
nous sommes en train de finir les
travaux de l'ifi c'est l'école
d'infirmières qui va donc prendre place
sur la caserne pittié et formé plus
d'étudiants par le passé là aussi il ya
progression mais pour aller plus loin
demain dont le programme que je défends
l'idée est d'abord de développer et
d'adapter les filières de bts ce que
tout n'est pas enseignement supérieur
il faut penser aussi aux filières
courtes professionnalisantes qui sont
extrêmement efficaces pour trouver du
travail
et je pense que la structure des bts
actuelle n'est pas assez proche du
bassin d'emploi donc les tournées vers
les entreprises verront voir nous allons
ouvrir une classe préparatoire
j'ai obtenu l'accord sai et du rectorat
auprès de l'école de l'essab en arts
appliqués
nous allons et je suis très surpris que
vous ayez raté cet épisode du film nous
avons avec le président du conseil
général relancer le combat je les dis en
conseil municipal mais bon tout le monde
ne peut pas je comprends avoir toute
l'information mais au moins 1 messieurs
on attaque et pas sur le sujet nous
soutenons la démarche de l'ouverture de
la fac de médecine à nevers et ce combat
est mené par le président du conseil
général
nous sommes en bonne avancée c'est très
dur avec la faculté de dijon
je ne voudrais pas être désagréable avec
vous messieurs les dijonnais mais un
nouvel enseignant recrutement un parfait
nous sommes à nevers parfois un peu loin
de dijon et surtout la distance est plus
longue dans un sens que dans un autre
dire que quand les gens viennent à dijon
voilà c'est ça va c'est pas trop long
mais quand les dijonnais via nano vert
c'est toujours trop long donc on nous
travaillons avec l'université de
clermont pour avancer et puis je crois
qu'il faut aussi s'occuper
d'apprentissage mais tout ça n'a de sens
que dans le cadre d'un projet de re
développement du tissu économique local
et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est parce qu'il y aura de l'emploi
gars y aura de la jeunesse monsieur bien
d'années a tout perdu combien d'années à
temps perdu vous allez pouvoir nous le
dira en conclusion puisque il nous reste
là d une poignée de minutes dans cette
émission on arrive à la dernière partie
vous allez conclure chacun votre tour
dans un ordre déterminé par tirage au
sort juste avant le début de ce débat
vous avez chacun 45 secondes pour cette
conclusion et nous commençons par denis
curieux
écoutez je sais pas si c'est le sort qui
s'acharne je suis en a sur les panneaux
électoraux je ne sais pas si c'est
prémonitoire je l'espère en tout cas
simplement rapidement je reste une 10
mais j'ai toujours été sans étiquette
avec des personnes qui m'ont rejoint je
suis nos versoix je suis avocat j'ai
fait le choix de revenir dans ma ville
après des études à dijon à grenoble et
j'ai la chance peut-être on me prête
cette qualité de fédérer les gens de les
rassembler je pense que je voulais
démontrer aujourd'hui faut passer à
autre chose et non vers soi je vous
l'assuré n'en peuvent plus donc nous
proposons nous offrons cette autre voie
cette nouvelle voie qui dérange je le
conçois mais qui est une force
aujourd'hui et en laquelle beaucoup de
personnes ont donné leur voix donc je
vous
demande si vous voulez que nos verres
changé nous sommes la seule force en
position de le faire autre que le parti
socialiste est bien de voter bien de
voter à pour l'avenir de nos verres
votez nevers à venir merci florent
sainte fare garnot vous tiré le numéro 2
d'abord j'aimerais aux 9 et reçoit
l'ancien appel au vote pour que ce vote
cette élection dimanche soit la vôtre et
que vous ayez choisi élus votre mère la
deuxième chose c'est de vous dire que
nous présentons le seul projet de gauche
le seul projet crédible et porté par une
équipe cohérente capable de durer six
ans et non pas six semaines comme une
élection une campagne pour une élection
municipale
ensuite nous engageons à travailler pour
vous pour vos services publics pour
votre pouvoir d'achat et pour l'emploi
et enfin pour terminer je vous dirai
simplement cette choses élémentaires
vous me connaissez je suis votre mère je
suis à côté de vous chaque jour
dimanche j'ai besoin de vous et jamais
je ne trahirai votre confiance
merci sam fare garnot christophe
gaillard et vous écoutez je voudrais
parler du front national et quand j'ai
dit tout à l'heure avec sourire que je
savourais un petit peu le fait d'être l'
arbitre entre ces deux formations
politiques qui accueille d'un côté la
droite de l'autre la gauche le
rassemblement de la gauche le
rassemblement de la droite voudrait
simplement dire que j'ai souri mais
quand je pense à toutes ces salades
politique je pense également
immédiatement à toutes les personnes qui
sont vulnérables les handicapés les
personnes âgées les chômeurs les jeunes
à nevers et je voudrais m'adresser à eux
et leur dire que le front national
aujourd'hui change de visage est le seul
à traiter les questions de l'immigration
de l'insécurité de l'emploi évidemment
et puis du social avec une certaine
priorité qui est donné d'abord aux
français
et puis je voudrais faire un appel
également moi aussi dire aux électeurs
qui se sont égarés sur la liste de
gauche est sur la liste d'options curio
de revenir à la maison le front national
leur maison merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci
d'avoir fait le chemin depuis neuf ans
nous arrivons donc au terme de cette
édition sachez que vous pouvez voir ou
revoir ce débat bien sûr sur notre site
internet bourgogne poids france 3 point
fr est le résumé de bien sûr de ces
discussions dans nos éditions
demain à midi et à 19 heures mais d'ores
et déjà sachez que france 3 bourgogne
sera mobilisée comme dimanche dernier
bien sûr pour la soirée électorale
nous serons en direct pour vous donner
tous les résultats en temps réel de 19
heures à 23 heures avec les réactions
des candidats et des points directs dans
toute la région
au 1er tour vous avez été très nombreux
à nous suivre france 3 était la chaîne
la plus regardée en bourgogne pendant
les émissions électorales on espère vous
retrouver aussi nombreux pour le
deuxième tour et ne sont d'ailleurs en
direct de nevers notamment mais aussi
auxerre sens montceau les mines
dijon et mâcon merci de votre attention
merci à tous et bonne nuit
et